or cette loi anticasseurs cette fermeté
c'est ce qu'on l'a compris du message du
premier ministre hier une fermeté qui se
traduira par un texte en février mais
après les violences de l'acte 8 et à
quelques jours de la ctt 9 n'est ce pas
trop tard on regarde le premier ministre
c'était donc hier soir sur tf1 il parle
de ces casseurs en tout cas je peux vous
dire qu'ils n'auront pas le dernier mot
depuis que ces événements ont commencé
lyon a procédé à des interpellations
nous veillons à ce que la justice puisse
condamner ceux qui se rendent
responsables de ces actes délictueux est
souvent très violents et afin de
garantir l'ordre public auquel nous
sommes tous attachés auquel les français
sont légitimement très attaché nous
avons pris la décision pour samedi
prochain vous faire en sorte d'assurer
une mobilisation considérable des forces
de l'ordre gentil kuzmanovic jeu nous a
privé sa mesure mais quelle celles qui
ont été détaillées annoncé hier par le
premier ministre avec une loi un projet
de loi sur pouvoir un peu sur le modèle
de ce qu'on fait avec les hooligans dans
le foot
et puis également sauf que ce ne sont
pas des hooligans dans le foot ce sont
d'ailleurs rarement d ultra gauche sont
rarement des ultra droite et le problème
c'est que monsieur philippe tu m'as pas
jusqu'au bout de du constat et il ne dit
pas quels sont les chiffres dès qu'ils
sortent des juges
dire qu'on a eus 534 note quasiment 2000
arrestations on à 219 1 440
incarcération des centaines de
comparution immédiate
et la plupart d'entre elles finissent
par des relations les chiffres 5600
garde à vue qui m'ont et là-dessus mille
condamnation essentielles sont des
rappels à la loi
eh oui si on parle d'un ce cas ça peut
être effectivement lors de deux cents
les gardes à vue elles sont plus
nombreux et donc la loi ne s'applique
pas pour des arrestations à titre
préventif par exemple est le
qualificatif de casseurs pour des
manifestants qui sont parfois on
constatait les juges ont été arrêtés
dans des espaces privés et non pas
public pose un vrai problème
on voit qu'il y à une répression très
forte
voulue par le gouvernement alors que on
est dans une situation grave sociale
économique et politique qui appellerait
une sortie politique et non pas une
sortie répressive qui je pense tournera
extrêmement mal comme le montrent les
derniers actes alexis pas la bonne
réponse c'est d'abord c'est évidemment
une écoute et mise en scène politique
c'est évident la vérité c'est que quand
jean philippe arles si les côtés session
de rattrapage ce qui s'est passé c'est
que le gouvernement s'est fait
absolument dé-bor-dée samedi dernier est
d'ailleurs la première mesure qu'ils
annoncent avant même de parler de cette
loi c'est de dire samedi prochain on va
mettre du monde on va remettre 80 mille
policiers et gendarmes dans les rues on
va ressortir le truc c'est que le
gouvernement celle ci paie la force de
raconter que l'affairé que le que le
mouvement décliner il avait fini par
croire à lui-même à ce qu'il racontait
et donc le gouvernement a été surpris il
n'y avait pas assez de policiers dans
les rues samedi dernier et le fait que
quinze gars puisque quasiment prendre
d'assaut un ministère c'est absolument
invraisemblable enfin il là il ya un
vrai problème de on peut on peut
reparler ensuite des lois mais en terme
de maintien de l'ordre que quinze type
réussissent à prendre vraiment très fin
on se demande ce que fait le préfet de
police la ja il ya un vrai problème
technique est donc cette cette
intervention martial du premier ministre
elle sert aussi à ça c'est à faire
oublier ce ratage est à dire on va
prendre des mesures après les mesures
évidemment elle résoudrons pas tous est
évident que là on est dans un vrai
problème politique c'est pas par des
mesures sécuritaires contraindrait chose
après tout ne sont pas inutiles moyenne
qui m'intéresse c'est notamment celle
sur l'interdiction de manifester en
cagoule c'est vrai que l'idée de dire
que le droit à manifester les garanties
pourquoi est ce qu'on est en train de
mettre une cagoule si on mène cagoule
c'est qu'on a quelque chose à cacher
c'est parce qu'on va casser à ce moment
là moi je trouve qu interdire les
cagoules madiot non bah c'est pas tout à
fait pareil si moi j'avais un strict de
par la police et les casseurs ça me
paraît difficile à tenir
alexis ne disais pas anticipé
effectivement un peu un rattrapage un
gouvernement on a l'impression qu'il ya
un décalage google événement même par
les 4000 personnes ou les personnes qui
ont les soi-disant casseurs mais le
problème de ce discours je trouve en
l'écoutant c'est que l'autorité n'est
pas performative c'est pas parce qu'on
dit qu'on a de l'autorité qu'on en a
c'est exactement l'inversé
c'est pas en disant je vais avoir le
dernier mot qu'on a dernier mot c'est
justement exactement le contraire
on a eu un après j'avais l'impression en
l'écoutant voir un père devant son
adolescent violent qui le craint et qui
sait pas quoi faire en disant juste
j'aurai le dernier mot moi je pense
exactement l inverse donc quand on n'a
pas d'autorités parce qu'il ya plus de
crainte en face il n'y a pas d'autorité
sans crainte il ya plus de craint en
fait ce don qui n'a pas d'autorité du
coup on adopte un langage autoritariste
on menace on légifère on fiche alors moi
je me suis amusé ce que je me dis on est
le pays où les champions du monde de la
fiche on à 58 fish avait regardé le
dossier type de fiches différentes et
dans la fiche s y en a 16 simplement le
fish la fiche c'est le signe qu'on va
agir mais ce n'est pas l'action quand
ton fils nos choses vont vraiment nous
dit qu'on ne peut pas s'appuyer sur les
fiches pour prendre des mesures bâle en
face à moi même pour les fichiers s on
voit très bien qu'un fichier s n'empêche
pas on ne peut pas arrêter un fish est
un qui a pas eu d'attentât donc la fiche
c'est comme quand on fait ses bonnes
résolutions avec moi écrit sur des
fiches on a l'impression qu'on agit mais
on agit pas du tout il ya encore un
grand écart entre les deux problèmes
d'autorité énorme problème de mise en
action et me semble-t-il une journée
c'est quand je pense que d'ailleurs
l'autorité a été de moins en moins
performative parce que ça n'a pas
commencé et week-end dernier
depuis le 27 novembre on a à chaque fois
la nécessité d'adapter une réponse à des
formes de manifestations violentes qui
était visiblement insuffisamment
anticipée donc le
pour un public ayant donné le sentiment
d'avoir une opération de maintien de
l'ordre de retard pour parler de guerre
de retard ce qui faisait partie l'égard
des griefs des français avec comme
caractéristique même extrêmement
frappante que lors du paroxysme du du
1er décembre avec la mise à sac de la de
triompher les forces de l'ordre ont été
plusieurs fois repoussée on a une
opinion publique qui manifeste à la fois
une condamnation sans 0 ambiguïté des
violences tout en ne maintenant à un
niveau très élevé sont son soutien aux
mouvements dirigeants ce qui pose la
question derrière c'est tout le débat de
qui est responsable des violences
et qui est le fauteur de trouble dans
cette question des médias
il ya un vrai problème c'est que moi
j'ai fait quasiment tous les actes en
gilet jaune et il y a un nombre
incroyable de gilet jaune qui ont
défendu des commerces
il est des reportages sur d'autres
chaînes où vous avez des gens qui
commence à casser vous avez un cordon de
gilet jaune qui se met en place
les gens qui travaillent qu'ils savaient
qu'ils lisent et on l'a pas vu je vois
vous avez encore rediffusé ce monsieur
qui va boxer un policier nantes alors
c'est une très mauvaise idée
je suis mais non c'est mauvais dit de sa
part oui et donc sa nouvelle montre et
oui mais on montre que c'est là où vous
savez très bien on pourrait montrer au
moins à égalité ce derby c'est qui qui
tabasse des gens à toulon au moins et
puis surtout la plupart des jets et
jaune ne font pas ça il ya aussi des
éléments d'exaspération et de
provocation
on peut évidemment les violences
policières quand elles existent sont
condamnables mais on ne peut pas mettre
sur un pied d'égalité trailer vous le
faisiez sur le ton de la blague en
disant les armes drogue pour tandis que
la gauche
oui oui mais hélas vous leur faites sur
le ton du sérieux en disant oui eux en
mettant sur un strict - d'égalité les
violences policières il en est 15 heures
je pense que c'est quand même pas tout à
fait pareil les violences policières
certes son quant à des églises sont
condamnables mais malgré tout grâce
entre les gens qui défendent la loi et
les gens qui viole ouvertement la loi
tous nos règles c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose
mais malgré tout dans l'ombre à leur
dire un point partout quand on sait pas
les cowboys et les indiens passé voilà
il pas des gens tu partes ont quand même
font la loi mais les policiers défendre
et puis c'est le ferment des moyens
excessifs parfois en forme ces jeunes et
policiers dans les ordres qui reçoivent
du préfet est donc de mise l'intérieur
c'est facile c'est pas facile à écouter
moi j'ai vu des exactions et je suis
certain que les policiers ne décide pas
eux-mêmes de tirer à bout portant aussi
massivement des milliers de tirs
lacrymogènes et les affrontements y est
toujours méchant envers soi puisque
l'ordre et je pense pas qu'on leur dise
tiraient sur les gens mais simplement
ils s'en prennent plein la figure et à
un moment il s'énerve et est depuis
qu'il ya des manifestions depuis que le
monde est monde sait quand même que si
j'ai une question plus globale peut-être
julia de funès sur et finalement est ce
qu'on peut continuer à manifester gilet
jaune on dit quand ça génère de telles
violences est ce qu'on peut continuer à
dire mais moi je suis un gilet jaune
pacifique et je ne veux pas exprimer
toute la responsabilité d'aider des
jeunes c'est vrai que je trouve ça un
peu facile mais je comprends en même
temps d'accuser des médias parce que
maintenant n'importe qui parle un peu
fort et médiatisée c'est quand même pas
un droit un privilège de passer dans les
médias et je trouve que dans ce
mouvement dg des jeunes justement il ya
deux je me souviens plus des prénoms
enfin la jeune fille est jeune homme qui
se sont bien démarqués et gilet jaune
mais je trouve qu'il a une
responsabilité énorme gilet jaune à se
dire à s'inscrire en faux contre ces
casseurs et ça on l'a on commence à le
voir mais je trouve qu'on n'a pas vu de
façon si prégnante que sa balle fatale
moi je crois pas qu'on puisse faire
il n'y a pas d'un côté des très gentil g
jour notre côté très méchants casseurs
la vie c'est plus compliqué que ça la
vie s'éteint c'est un continuum et le
même gilet jaune peut être gentil le
matin s énerver le soir et le même
casseurs peuvent commencer par
manifester gentiment alors hier des
casseurs professionnels
ça c'est vrai il ya des pillards qui
viennent de banlieue c'est vrai aussi
il ya des gilet jaune qui pour rien au
monde ne ferez quoi que ce soit
c'est vrai plaisir qu'il ya un entre
deux et il ya une radicalisation du
gentil gilet jaune qui devient méchant
mais un double intérêt c'est dire que
les îles de jeunes sont les casseurs ils
sont moins visibles ils sont moins bien
vendu et des casseurs sans les
particules passe officiellement dit bah
oui il y en a qui casse alors c'est pas
bien même temps six est pas cassé
si on veut être entendu il faut bien
qu'il continue parce qu est ce qu un
moment dire stop on arrête interdiction
des manifestations avec ce que ça peut
générer d'autres violences c'est mais
c'est intéressant d'aborder les choses
comme rappelant qu'ils aient pas des
gentils des méchants parce qu'en fait le
débat s'organise toujours quand on parle
de questions d'emploi des forces de
l'ordre ou d'ailleurs de réponse pénale
dans cette espèce d'illusion un peu
hollywoodienne qui serait que la vie ce
serait de punir les méchants de protéger
de les gentils or dans la réalité de la
réponse pénale comme de l'emploi des
forces de l'ordre on est toujours dans
un curseur qu'on déplace entre le risque
de punir les innocents ou le risque
d'attraper indulgent avec des coupables
et tout le débat politique il doit
tourner autour de ça il se trouve que
c'est vrai que la manière dont les gens
s'approprient non non je vois le voit
dans les dents les discussions qu'on
suscite quand on interroge les gens et
ils ont cette vision qui s'imposent mais
qui est très dans notre culture un de
dire il ya des méchants il faut les
identifier les punir il ya des gentils
il faut il faut les protéger et c'est ce
débat entre les gens qui rient jaune l
élégie les jeunes qui seraient des
casseurs oui il ya un continuum de même
que c'est très compliqué d'imaginer un
emploi plus ferme de l'aude et des
forces de l'ordre sans qu'il y ait des
débordements et c'est très compliqué
donc vous voyez imaginer un emploi plus
ferme des forces de l'ordre sans qu'il y
ait des bavures mais on ne peut pas
déclencher un mot et puis on peut pas
déconnecter cela de la crise sociale
tient quand même encore une fois la
plupart des gilets jaunes qui sont
arrêtés même ceux qui sont incarcérés ne
sont pas des experts de la violence
politique
c'est un constat donc ce sont des gens
qui a trois mois n'aurait jamais imaginé
faire ce qu'il faisait à un moment donné
quand nos pouvoirs et qu'on a ça comme
indicateur on doit réfléchir très
sérieusement politiquement à ce qui se
passe dans le pays et malheureusement
visiblement ce pouvoir là ne s'intéresse
pas à toute la violence sociale
accumulée pour que des gens en arrivent
là je rappelle que les 12 et 13 juillet
les français se sont attaqués aux
barrières d'octroi aux fermiers généraux
aucun ressemble un peu maintenant les
concessionnaires d'autoroutes et à tout
un tas de prébendes conte un certain
nombre
très très riches en france ça serait une
très bonne idée de calme et
politiquement cette violence là aussi
qui crée je pense en dehors des vrais
nbc qui casse mais il ya une violence
comme il dit qui est de fait de gens
simples qui séduit un simple y compris
le boxer ça va pas vous faire plaisir
d'avoir parlé quand même deux minutes
qui explique dans cette vidéo après
avoir boxé sur le gendarme mobile samedi
explique dans sa vidéo ben ça m'a
dépassé j'ai été pris de colère
j'ai été gazés et ma compagne aussi et
donc ça justifie selon lui donc annoncé
un raisonnement archi faux alors ça
c'est un raisonnement qui ne tient pas
une seconde on a l'impression que les le
vide du cerveau meubles les testicules
avec ce boxeur
non j'y vais franchement mais parce que
c'est un raisonnement qui ne peut pas
tenir une honte et un raisonnement qui
ne peut pas tenir parce que si on
commence à expliquer les raisons
d'action on peut très bien trouver des
raisons d'agir des policiers s'ils ont
gazé c'est aussi parce qu'ils avaient
des raisons d'agir et on ne sort pas et
en plus c'est de contredire la mairie ma
saison de regret c'est qu'il y avait des
gens en face et ces gens en face avait
des raisons d'agir et on n'en finit pas
céder dire que les raisons d'agir ne
doivent pas amendée l'évaluation des
actes le commandent ya aucun agresseur
n'est la victime de sa proie
c'est quelque chose qui ne tient pas
c'est un réseau un raisonnement faux
seins paralogisme prend le juge il sera
il dit ce monsieur ira en procès en juin
oblige évaluera les actes évaluera les
allées il écoutera les circonstances
proposé par la milliardaire lui les
actes et mais néanmoins on peut pas
faire un focus à ce point c'est pas bien
ce qu'a fait ce monsieur il l'a dit
peut-être que les sections à travers 3
pour prendre trop cher mais c'est quand
même un peu d'hommes alors la sofcot et
donne un coup de pied là mais au début
la tanière non au début ils attaquent
avec des points et des forces de l'ordre
c'est pas non plus le séparant goût du
terroriste ultra violents ont donné un
meilleur traitement les gendarmes autour
de leurs collègues ont dit s'il avait pu
le tuer si le jeter dans la seine
c'était des manifestants les sur des
passerelles pardon seul déjà le truc de
là vous avez le dispositif j'étais là
j'étais je voyage à m vous avez avec 10
10 10 pauvre gendarmes ou crs tout seul
ce gendarme tout seul mais entouré par
des gens j'ai bac il acquit à fait
disposée
ce à quoi on dirait que c'est provoquer
alors j'ai une question pour emmanuel
rivière
le conseil est une cagnotte levé sur
litchi qui a réuni en quelques heures
plus de cent mille euros ça là aussi ça
prouve qu'un soutien ça pose la question
c'est parce que les personnes qui
participent et 28000 personnes 28
millions vingt-huit personnes ont
participé à cette cagnotte au moment où
elle a été fermée et je disais tout à
l'heure que la condamnation des
violences par les français elle est
massive
mais elle n'est pas unanime et je pense
qu'il faut s'interroger aussi sur ces
quelques mains % de français qui disent
qu'ils comprennent qu'ils s'interrogent
et je pense que tout vous dire j'ai
quelques inquiétudes sur l'état de santé
de notre démocratie et on voit un
certain nombre des piliers très
sérieusement fissurer le regard porté
sur les médias le regard porté sur nos
institutions
henin qui est très important c'est là
qu'elle a la reconnaissance par chacun
du monopole de la violence légitime
on est en train de s'interroger sur cet
exercice delà de ce monopole de la
violence légitime par l'est les forces
de l'ordre on est en train de se dire
est ce que leur violence ne mérite pas
une violence en retour et sans
d'ailleurs que mon propos ne consistent
à départager qui que ce soit il ya une
vraie interrogation enfin regarder les
débats tels qu'ils s'organisent sur les
médias sociaux ces vidéos contre vidéo
toulon contre la passerelle sédar
senghor et ce canyon centre le gagnant à
trier et donc voilà ça c'est un premier
policier ou il me semble que c'est un
vrai constat d'un problème dans une
démocratie il se passe vraiment quelque
chose de très de très grave
et là je rejoins même si c'est pas du
même parce que des gens les cosmonautes
ont ce que nous disent ce cette cagnotte
ce que nous disent ce soutien persistant
au mouvement avant la veille du week-end
dernier on avait pu lire un sondage
avait encore après tout ce qui s'était
passé après toutes les concessions qui
était pas qu'ils avaient encore 55% des
français qui soutenaient la poursuite du
mouvement manifestations etc
donc ça nous dit ça nous dit quelque
chose du discrédit qui frappe les
classes dirigeants de la détestation que
la france d'en bas vous à la france d'en
haut d'une sorte de haine sociale qui a
sans doute toujours existé dans ce pays
mais qui s'est réveillé dans ces
dernières années que les sept paradoxe
de ce gouvernement qui est élu sur le
projet de bienveillance de
réconciliation on a réveillé une guerre
des classes dont on sait pas où elle va
nous mener
c'est absolument car c'est pour ça que
je ne crois pas un instant jeu que des
mesures sécuritaires fusse-t-elle
nécessaire suffiront à résoudre tout ça
on est dans un processus politique qui
va être très long très compliqué et dont
aujourd'hui personne comment on peut
sortir parce que si quelqu'un peut dire
comment le gouvernement peut sortir de
cette affaire-là
alors là bravo quand même à une violence
morale envers les citoyens avec les rien
et habillez vous achetez ou un costume
faisait pas assez cotisé qui sont
délirants au point président parce que
je sais pas de quoi satisfaire 19 pouces
fait c'est la haine de soi disant très
loin devant sarkozy et il ya quand même
souci mais dans l'anecdote c'est vrai il
était très maladroit il énervé les gens
ce qui les énerve volume il ya autre
chose je pense au fond que notamment le
projet fondamental dans marche et de
maquereau qui le dépassement du clivage
droite-gauche jones à dire quand il ya
plus de clivage droite gauche
et dieu sait qu il est agaçant et dieu
sait qu il est énervant je me réjouis et
je sais qu'il est parfois caricatural
mais n'empêche que quand il ya plus qu
il va je crois de gauche quand il ya
plus cette canalisation de rigueur
sociale sous une forme dans un chemin
idéologique d'accueillir plus de vaches
laitières les pauvres contre les riches
c'est exactement ce qu'on est en train
de vivre social il n'y a pas plus de
syndic rien mais bien sûr c'est bien que
c'était bien bien des combats du bon
sens
c'est la première fois qu'on a un
mouvement social de cette ampleur qu'ils
soient pas implicitement soutenu
davantage à droite qu'à gauche ou à
gauche qu'à droite comme c'était le cas
de la manif pour tous des mouvements qui
elle commence et c'est en fait les
franges de l'espace politique contre
contre le centre est revenu c'est très
clair quand on regarde les 55 conscience
qu'ils soutiennent contre l'acteur n'a
pas été indexé de façon absolument
linéaire sur le niveau de revenu plus on
est pourvue en détient plus on est riche
plus on condamne ça pose comme un
problème parce que d'abord les riches
sont moins nombreux que les pauvres et
c'est eux qui gouvernent les pauvres ils
sont où ils sont au gouvernement mais
ils sont majoritaires donc si on
laissait deux quintés contre l'autre sa
filiale petit peut-être un peu exotique
mais le la manifestation annoncée du 27
janvier les foulards rouges et ça ça
c'est dangereux ça peut être une
contre-manifestation c'est donc c'est
dans une démocratie fausse de corée du
nord qu'on pouvoir organiser des
manifestations en soutien aux dirigeants
que ce truc va sérieusement épicier 1968
gouvernement l'espoir de sa queue que la
réalité des violences
l'area mouvement de solidarité de khalid
ou de flaques de solidarité autour du
président et que mais force est de
constater que ça se marchent pas du tout
aidé mais que et voilà et dire macron au
fond l'idée c'est que les la peur du
désordre va faire va provoquer un
ralliement notamment des couches modérée
de la droits des retraités et aidera à
maquereau le problème c'est que j'ai le
sentiment qu'aujourd'hui macro lui-même
assimilé au désordre
donc les gens qui veulent pas ce donc
même ceux qui condamnent les désordres
pour autant n'ont pas envie de soutenir
raconte la majorité soutient g jaune 75
% des français considèrent que cette
prise en des riches
c'est pas la considération qu'ils
avaient les français du général de
gaulle qu'à sauver le pays qui l'a remis
au firmament des nations unies macron il
ay vraiment il plane en fait un dernier
et sonores sur ce point qui est
intéressant c'est toujours françois de
rugy ce matin alors il lui sur les
violences il dit il faudrait quand même
que les condamnations soient un petit
peu plus nombreuses et unanime en écoute
sur tout ce que je vois c'est les
députés par exemple ce sont les députés
de la majorité
un qui sont ciblés c'est quasiment tous
les jours qu'ils reçoivent des lettres
d'un sud
des lettres de menaces de mort des
lettres raciste ou des lettres sexy ou
surtout des agressions non seulement sur
leurs permanences de député mais sur ce
qu'il est encore beaucoup plus grave sur
leurs domiciles privés
une députée de vendée patricia
gallerneau s'est réveillé dimanche matin
avec un mur de parpaings qui avait été
construite dans sa sortie de garage et à
un moment donné où tous les responsables
politiques devraient condamner cela les
agressions contre les députés alors le
problème de ce gouvernement c'est que
après ne pas avoir condamné benalla il
est peu crédible dans la condamnation
des violences ça c'est une chose parce
que ça laisse les grains qui travaillait
à l'elysée et qui visiblement continue
plus ou moins travaillé pour l'elysée
l'autre chose c'est que il ne se rend
pas compte nous on n'a pas vu ça depuis
la grande peur la grande peur c'est
personne n'a organisé cm cic gilet jaune
personnes hyper ce n'est même pas
poutine
personne n'est derrière pour leur dire
mettez départ pas là mettez du papier
toilette engueuler que ce soit bien ou
mal c'est pas le problème
ça se fait c'est comme la dernière fois
en france à rêver c'est la grande peur
c'est quand le peuple spontanément est
allé chez ces seigneurs prendre les
marques de taille pour ne plus payer
l'impôt et ne pas comprendre qu'il ya un
gros problème de justice sociale et de
justice fiscale dans ce pays et que si
on ne règle pas je pense que ça tournera
mal parce que ce genre de choses ne sont
jamais arrivés mais ça va même au delà
de ces fiscales et pris de malaise
identitaire d'inquiétude culturel ya
mille choses qui nourrissent c'est ce
sentiment de relégation de toute une
partie d'eux des gens qui habitent dans
ce pays c'est évident qu'il ya un vrai
ressentiment une vraie volonté punitives
contre les dirigeants toutes leurs
formes
quelque chose de très contre-productive
dans tout ça c'est que le jour où les
députés considérons qu'il est trop cher
ou trop dangereux d'avoir des
permanences parlementaires pourra plus
trop se plaindre qu'ils soient éloignés
des gens et qu'ils ne prennent plus le
transport en commun et oui si c'est
aussi la conséquence c'est qu'il ya
quelque chose quand même très très
violent contre beaucoup de militants pas
que enfin je pense que à la france a
soumis
un tout petit peu fait l'expérience
autre ancienne formation politique
quand ils ont voulu arriver avec les
balles jeux sur certains sur certains
basculent à la violence de ce mouvement
contre les syndicats est quelque chose
de terriblement injuste quand on sait ce
que c'est que le militantisme syndical
au quotidien dans les entreprises et ça
s'est produit aussi donc il ya
effectivement quelque chose qui déborde
quelques réactions on arrête gentil
qu'ousmane donne la parole à nos
internautes
alors avec d'abord germain qui nous dit
cette loi annoncé par philippe pétain
inutile et portera davantage atteinte au
droit de manifester la réponse doit être
politique et non pas sécuritaire côté
maintien de l'ordre ajoute il faudrait
prendre exemple sur l'allemagne et son
principe de désescalade
je sais pas si l'un d'entre vous connais
le maintien de l'ordre en allemagne clos
entre novembre et maintenant la
situation a évolué le gouvernement
s'adapte afin d'essayer de mieux gérer
cette citation cette situation
dramatique et on vous poser la question
la nouvelle loi
durcissant les sanctions contre les
casseurs arrive-t-elle trop tard vous
êtes deux tiers estimé que oui elle est
trop tardive cette loi nicole ajoute le
premier ministre veut faire croire que
le gouvernement réagit mais tout ce
qu'il a annoncé ne sera pas effectif
avant au moins février et monsieur
babineau nous dit le gouvernement a
toujours un coup de retard par rapport
au mouvement dg des jaunes c'est
effectivement ce qu'on ait évoqué oui
c'est clairement insuffisant sur le
court terme